ahora que sabemos un poco más sobre
listas en python pensé usar este vídeo
para introducirlos en los ciclos de
programación particularmente en el ciclo
for
si nos da tiempo probablemente veamos
otros tipos de ciclos pero antes quiero
mostrarles una función que viene con
python y que se llama range lo que hace
esta función es generar una lista una
lista que contiene una serie de enteros
que se incrementan por ejemplo si uso
range de 6 crea una lista que contiene
los elementos de 0 a 5 son 6 elementos
hasta 6 pero sin incluirlo si quisiera
incluir en 6 tendría que hacer range de
7 y generaría una lista de todos los
enteros hasta 7 sin incluir 7 por lo que
tendría el 6 en mi lista si quiero tener
del 1 al 6 osea no quiero tener el 0
entonces hago un range empezando en 1
incluyendo el 1 y hasta 7 pero sin
incluir 7 así que el primer elemento en
la función si se incluye pero el último
elemento no sé
y aquí vamos obtenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 y lo
que es padre de este entorno de
desarrollo integrado ide en inglés este
país script er que estoy usando es que
si tecleamos una función la reconoce y
me da información sobre esta función
por si acaso hemos olvidado cómo se usa
no sé si puedan leer esto que está aquí
pero dice range start stop step así que
podemos decirle a nuestra función range
el incremento que queremos en los
elementos de la lista en este momento el
incremento es 1 en cada elemento pero
podemos decirle que queremos incrementar
en una cantidad distinta así que le
decimos que queremos una lista range
empezando en cero y hasta 8 pero sin
incluir 8 incrementando de dos en dos en
lugar de uno entonces obtenemos 0246
quiero dejar claro esto una vez más el 8
no se incluye en la lista
parte alta de la función no se incluye y
genera la lista incrementando el valor
de los elementos de dos en dos así que
pueden usar la función de esta manera
tal vez podrían empezar en tres y llegar
hasta el 31
sin incluir 31 e incrementando de 3 en 3
vamos a ver lo que hace la función range
generó una lista empezando en 3
incrementando de 3 en 3
hasta 31 pero sin incluir 31 y la razón
de que sea tan útil esta función es que
podemos usarla en ciclos y el primer
ciclo en el que los voy a introducir es
el ciclo por esta parte de aquí es el
intérprete ahora voy a escribir un
programa acá arriba este programa es
para mostrarles cómo hacer un ciclo for
así que digo por iu y es una variable
que generalmente se usa en los ciclos
fort en ciclos interactivos iterativo
significa que haces una cosa una y otra
vez for y en
voy a hacer algo simple digamos range de
5 esto me va a generar una lista 0 1 2 3
4 así que para iu en range de 5 y estos
dos puntos indican que hay instrucciones
para cada una de las iteraciones vamos a
decir print y imprime y imprime el valor
de cada vez y antes de que veamos lo que
hace vamos a pensarlo esto significa que
cada vez que repetimos el ciclo y hace
referencia al valor de cada uno de los
elementos de la lista que genera la
función range cada vez que pasa por el
ciclo toma un valor diferente y se
imprime así que vamos a ver lo que hace
déjenme salvar el programa y correrlo
aquí vamos lo que hizo fue crear un
ciclo y cada vez que pasa por las
instrucciones cada valor de la lista es
asignado a la variable i y como
recordarán los elementos de esta lista
son
1 2 3 y 4 0 1 2 3 4 hasta 5 pero sin
incluirlo así que cada vez que entras en
el ciclo y pasa a través de todos estos
elementos y este programa lo que hace es
imprimir el valor de y entonces la
primera vez y es 0 y se imprime 0 luego
imprime 1 y luego imprime 2 y luego
imprime 3 y luego imprime 4 lo hace así
las veces que sea necesario para los
elementos de la lista si le digo que
haga range de 10 y vamos a correr el
programa veremos que imprime del 1 al 9
mejor dicho del 0 al 9 porque 0 es el
primer elemento de la lista pero podemos
hacer cosas más interesantes
digamos que queremos obtener la suma de
0 a 9 entonces lo que podemos hacer es
definir otra variable aquí la variable
suma y antes de hacer otra cosa suma va
a ser igual a 0 y podemos decir cada vez
que pasamos por el ciclo definimos a la
variable suma con el valor anterior de
suma
el valor que tiene en esta parte del
ciclo vamos a ver qué hace el programa
déjenme salvarlo y correrlo aquí vamos
cada vez que pasamos por el ciclo la
primera vez sume 0 y el valor de y es 0
lo sumamos e imprimimos el valor de suma
que obtuvimos que es 0 la siguiente vez
pasamos por el ciclo y entonces y vale 1
y lo sumamos al valor anterior de suma
que es 0 y lo imprimimos obtenemos 1 la
siguiente vez que pasamos por el ciclo
iba a ser 2 y lo sumamos al valor
anterior de suma que es 1 y obtenemos 3
la siguiente vez y es tres los sumamos
al valor anterior de suma y obtenemos 6
y la suma de todos los números de 0 a 9
es 45 justo aquí este es realmente un
programa útil pero para dejar esto más
claro dejen explicarles en mi tableta
cierra el país criterio
y copio el código
y lo pongo aquí vamos a pensar cómo
funciona esto tenemos un par de
variables vamos a partir de aquí con la
variable suma igual a cero y existen dos
maneras de visualizar las variables una
manera común que no es la más correcta
es pensar en ellas como contenedores
pero en python la manera correcta de ver
las variables sobre todo cuando usamos
listas es ver que una variable apunta
hacia algo a un valor así que si vemos
los contenedores podríamos decir ok en
el contenedor suma tenemos cero pero la
realidad es que suma está apuntando a
una literal numérica que tiene un valor
igual a cero en alguna parte de la
memoria ahora entramos en el ciclo for y
lo que el ciclo dice es asignemos el
valor de cada uno de los elementos de la
lista generada por la función range de
10 a la variable y así que para tener
esto claro esta función range de 10
genera una lista que se ve como esta
0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 y 9 hasta 10 pero sin
incluirlo esta es la lista de 10
elementos y cuando entramos al ciclo for
la primera vez déjenme escribirlo aquí
lo haré pensando en esto de dos maneras
lo haré pensando en esto como un
contenedor así que aquí tenga el
contenedor de la variable y la variable
y solo la usaremos dentro de esta
cláusula ya hablaremos más sobre el
alcance de las variables en este caso y
sólo la podemos usar dentro de esta
cláusula la variable suma la puedo usar
donde sea fuera de esta cláusula y
dentro de ella porque la definimos fuera
de la cláusula así que tenemos sí y esto
que tenemos aquí es el contenedor de iu
y en la primera iteración asignamos ahí
este primer elemento el valor de i es
cero en realidad la mejor manera de
pensar en esto es que y se está
refiriendo a este primer elemento la
primera vez que pasa por el ciclo
luego pasamos por el ciclo y dice aquí
suma vale 0 y 0 la sumamos y obtenemos
cero así que suma seguirá siendo cero o
suma seguirá refiriéndose a cero y luego
imprimimos suma esta línea de aquí esta
instrucción imprime el valor de suma que
es
entonces el programa regresa nuevamente
al ciclo y dice hay más elementos que se
le puedan asignar ahí claro que si
quedan todos estos elementos que deben
ser asignados a la variable y ahora y es
el siguiente elemento en la secuencia o
pensando en los contenedores
si queremos verlo de esta manera en el
contenedor y ahora está el 1 y corremos
esto nuevamente y decimos ok suma es 0 +
i y es 1 ahora suma se va a referir a 1
o en esta otra forma de pensar suma se
va a referir a 1 y cuando imprime suma
el programa imprimirá 1 y volvemos al
ciclo ford hay más elementos en esta
lista que pueden ser asignados ahí o
claro que si quedan todos estos así que
déjenme continuar y ahora será igual a 2
y se refiere a 2 si piensas en
contenedores aquí hay un 2 o y se
refiere a 2 y pueden ignorar todo esto
que está aquí y vamos al ciclo otra vez
ahora es 11 massey y ahora es 212 estrés
así que suma ahora será 3 en esta parte
del ciclo suma se refiere a 3 imprimimos
suma y obtenemos 3 y continuamos con el
ciclo mientras haya elementos a los que
se pueda referir el programa sigue con
las iteraciones si seguimos
incrementando y y tenemos valores aquí
eventualmente y serán 9 y se evaluará
esto hay algo más en la lista que pueda
ser asignado ahí y la respuesta es no ya
no hay nada en la lista así que el ciclo
se completa se rompe el ciclo y el
programa termina y esto es exactamente
lo que vemos cuando corremos el programa
en esta parte